We now know what an oxidation
state or an oxidation number
is and what it means
when things
are oxidized or reduced.
So let's see how that actually
happens in reactions.
So what we're going to study
in this video is oxidation
slash reduction reactions.
All that is is a reaction
where somebody's being
oxidized, which means that
electrons are being taken away
from them, and someone's being
reduced, which means that
they're being handed electrons,
or they're taking
electrons away from
someone else.
Sometimes this has been termed--
because you have the
R-E-D in reduction and you have
the ox in oxidation, and
they switch them around and
they call this a redox
reaction, which sounds like a
very fancy chemistry term, but
it just means a reaction where
something is getting oxidized.
And if something is getting
oxidized, something else is
getting reduced.
So let's study a
couple of them.
So right here, I actually
have combustion.
This is actually methane.
So methane is a fuel.
You can make a motor powered
on methane right there.
It's a hydrocarbon.
Most fuels that we use are
hydrocarbons, which just mean
carbons bonded in a bunch of
different ways to a bunch of
different hydrogens.
If you add enough heat for the
reaction to happen-- so its
activation energy you have to
put it in there with some
oxygen around-- it's going to
combust and it's going to
produce carbon dioxide and
water-- and I didn't put it
here-- and even more heat
than you put into it.
So it's actually an exothermic
reaction.
It produces more heat than
you put into it.
I'll do a lot more of that in
future videos on endothermic
and exothermic reactions.
But anyway, we care about the
oxidation and the reduction.
So let's see if anyone's getting
oxidized, or anyone is
getting reduced here.
So let's look at
their oxidation
numbers, or their states.
Here, carbon is bonded
to 4 hydrogens.
Who's giving, who's taking?
So let's go to our
Periodic Table.
Carbon is here.
Hydrogen is here.
Carbon is more electronegative.
It's adjacent to the
Three Musketeers of
electronegativity.
These guys are the most
electronegative.
We always ignore the noble gases
because they pretty much
don't react at all.
They're always happy with their
8 valence electrons.
These guys love to
get electrons.
They're small molecules.
Their outermost shell is
close to the nucleus.
They're so close to becoming
noble that they just love
hogging electrons.
Carbon's almost there.
Carbon's much further to the
right on the periodic table
than the hydrogen.
So if you have carbon bonding
with hydrogen, carbon is going
to be the electron hog.
So in the situation,
let's go down here.
So if carbon's the electron hog
and hydrogen is having its
electrons taken away from it--
remember, this is all kind of
hypothetical.
It's more partial,
is the reality.
But if you had to pick or
choose, hydrogen's going to
lose an electron each.
So it's going to have an
oxidation state of plus 1 for
each hydrogen.
You have 4 hydrogens each
giving up an electron.
So the carbon must be
taking 4 electrons.
So its oxidation number
is minus 4.
It's taken 4 electrons so its
charge will go down by 4.
So that's why it's negative.
Fair enough.
What's the oxidation state of
this oxygen right there?
Well, it's just bonded
to itself.
There's no reason to believe
that 1 oxygen should be able
to take any electrons
from another oxygen.
So it has a 0 oxidation state.
It's not hogging more than its
fair share of electrons that
it was essentially born with.
Now.
After the combustion
occurs, what are
the oxidation numbers?
Well, I have 2 oxygens
bonded with carbon.
Now we know oxidation
was, to some
degree, named after oxygen.
It is one of the most
electronegative.
Almost anything bonded with
oxygen is going to be giving
up its electrons.
We also know that oxygen likes
to take 2 electrons.
If it takes 1, it gets here.
If 2, it gets here.
It has a configuration like it
has 8 valence electrons.
So its typical oxidation
number is minus 2.
So carbon, in this in the
situation, each oxygen is
going to have a minus
2 oxidation number.
The carbon dioxide molecule
is neutral.
So everything has
to add up to 0.
The oxygens, you have 2 of
them, each of them with a
minus 2 oxidation number.
So that's minus 4.
So carbon must be plus 4, which
means that it has given
up 4 electrons, right?
Really it only has 4 electrons
to give up.
It has 1, 2, 3, 4 valence
electrons in its second shell,
which is its reactive shell.
So its oxidation number
is plus 4.
Now let's look at the water.
We've done about a bunch.
When the hydrogens each give up
an electron, they have an
oxidation number of 1.
Each oxygen takes 2 electrons.
There's only 1 of them.
So it's minus 2.
So what's going on here?
What's getting oxidized,
what's getting reduced?
You have the carbon.
It went from an oxidation number
of minus 4 an oxidation
number of plus 4.
So let me just draw what's
happening to the carbon.
Carbon goes from minus 4, which
means it's hogging 4
electrons, to a situation where
it's having 4 electrons
being hogged from it.
It's kind of giving
away 4 electrons.
So someplace in this process,
this guy must have given away
8 electrons.
This is a difference
of 8 electrons.
So plus 8 electrons.
So what's happened to carbon?
Carbon, has it been oxidized
or reduced?
Its charge has gone up.
So it hasn't been reduced.
Or the other way is that you
can say electrons have been
taken away from it.
So it has been oxidized.
Now, let's look at the
oxygen itself.
Oxygen, over here you have
4 oxygen molecules.
So I'll just write 4 oxygen
molecules here.
And they all have an oxidation
state of 0.
From an oxidation-number point
of view, they're neutral.
On the side, we have
2, and then we
have 4 oxygen molecules.
What's their oxidation state?
They're all minus 2.
So each of these oxygens must
have gained an electron.
So actually, let me let me
re-write this reaction.
Let me erase a little
bit of it.
Even better, let me just
move this over.
There you go.
Let me fill in that, so
aesthetically it's pleasing.
There you go.
All right.
So we have 4 oxygens with a 0
oxidation state turning into 4
oxygens with a minus
2 oxidation state.
So each of these 4 oxygens
took 2 electrons.
There's 4 of them, so we must
have gained 8 electrons.
So what happened to oxygen?
It's oxidation state went down,
or its hypothetical
charge went down, or its
charge was reduced.
So this is reduced oxygen.
What was it reduced by?
It was reduced by the carbon.
What was the carbon
oxidized by?
It was oxidized by the oxygen,
which oxygen tends to do.
It tends to oxidize things.
What is the oxidizing agent?
Well it's the thing that
did the oxidizing.
So the oxygen is the
oxidizing agent.
What is the reducing agent?
Well it's the thing that
did the reducing?
It's the reducing agent,
is the carbon.
So you see in this redox
reaction, carbon was oxidized.
It gave away 8 electrons from
this state to that state,
hypothetically, and oxygen
was reduced.
Its charge was reduced by a
total of 8 electrons, 2 for
each oxygen.
So its oxidation number
went down.
Let's do a couple more.
Each of the things that I
wrote-- just to kind of do a
side-note-- this is called a
half reaction, because I'm
writing just what happened
to the carbon.
Here I'm writing just what
happened to the oxygen.
I did ignore something.
I did ignore the hydrogen.
I encourage you to
do something like
this with the hydrogen.
But you'll see that
hydrogen was
neither oxidized or reduced.
On both sides of the equation,
all the hydrogens had a plus 1
oxidation state.
Let's do another one.
Here I have another combustion
situation.
This is what happened
to the Hindenburg.
They filled a balloon full of
hydrogen because they wanted
it to float, because hydrogen
is a very light gas.
Unfortunately, there must have
been a spark in the presence
of oxygen, and it combusted.
And actually, this is
what is used for a
rocket fuel as well.
If you have liquid hydrogen--
actually, I don't think they
have liquid hydrogen.
Well, I don't know enough
about rocket science.
I'll have to do another video
that in the future.
But let's look at the
oxidation states.
What's the oxidation state
of hydrogen here, in its
elemental form?
It's 0.
2 hydrogens bonded to each
other, no reason why they
should hog or be hogged
by another hydrogen.
2 oxygen molecules or atoms
bonded to each other?
Once again, 0 oxidation state.
Once they combust and
form water, what's
their oxidation states?
We've done this multiple
times.
The oxygen has a minus
2 oxidation state.
Each hydrogen has a plus 1.
So let's write the
half reactions.
We have 2 hydrogens that are
just happy as they are in
neutral state.
They end up being 2 H2's, or
we could have written 4
hydrogens, either way.
They turn into 2 hydrogen
molecules, because there's
actually 4 hydrogen atoms, with
a plus 1 oxidation state.
So they must have each given
away 1 electron.
Now, how many total hydrogens
are there?
There are 4.
So we must have given
away 4 electrons.
So this is a half reaction
for hydrogen.
Now.
Let's do the same thing
for our oxygen.
We have some oxygen here.
On the left-hand side, it has
a neutral oxidation state.
Then we end up with 2 oxygens
on the right-hand side.
I'll write it like this, 2O,
each with the minus 2
oxidation states.
So each of these oxygens must
have gotten 2 electrons.
So it got 2 electrons each,
or it gained 4 electrons.
So what was oxidized?
Oxidized means that electrons
were taken away from you.
The hydrogen was oxidized,
oxidized by oxygen.
What was reduced?
The oxygen was reduced
by the hydrogen.
If you actually add these two
reactions up, if you make this
the left-hand side of your
equation and you make this the
right-hand side of your
equation, you can say, OK,
let's remove the electrons
from both sides.
Then you'll end up with your
original reaction.
Just to make sure our
terminology is right, what's
our oxidizing agent?
It's the thing doing
the oxidizing.
It's the oxygen.
What's our reducing agent?
It's the hydrogen.
Let's do one more.
So here I have iron plus
some hydrochloric acid.
Let's say this is in an
aqueous solution.
You end up with iron (II)
chloride plus some hydrogen.
So let's do some oxidation
numbers.
I'll do it fast this time.
Iron is just by itself.
It's got a 0 oxidation state.
Hydrogen with chloride,
chloride's a halogen.
These guys love to
take electrons.
They love to take 1 electron.
They typically have a minus
1 oxidation state.
So the chlorine is going
to have minus 1.
The hydrogen is going
to be plus 1.
You add them together, you get
to a neutral compound.
Fair enough.
Now you go on this side.
What is chlorine's
oxidation state?
Well, once again, it always
likes to take 1 electron.
So this is minus 1.
But I have 2 chlorines here.
This is a neutral compound.
So the iron oxidation state
must be plus 2.
What about the hydrogen?
Now it's just in its
elemental form so
it's going to be neutral.
So it has a 0 oxidation state.
So what was oxidized?
Our iron went from neutral to
having 2 electrons taken away
from it, which may give
it a positive charge.
So plus 2 electrons
got taken away.
So this was oxidized.
What about the hydrogen?
The hydrogen went from 2
hydrogens with a plus 1 state,
and essentially, they
went to 2 hydrogen
with a neutral state.
So 2 electrons must have been
added to the hydrogens.
Their charge was reduced.
So they were reduced.
What were they reduced by?
They were reduced by the iron.
What was the iron oxidized by?
It was oxidized by
the hydrogen.
What about the chlorine?
The chlorine has a minus 1
oxidation number here.
It has a minus 1 oxidation
number here.
It was a neutral relative
to the redox reaction.
Anyway, I think you
get the point now.
You can do this with a
bunch of reactions.
But this will give you a little
bit more insight of
actually what's going
on, and who's
gaining or losing electrons.
In the future, it will also help
us think about a lot of
the structures of molecules.
Anyway, see you in
the next video.